[Music]
my name is Max Pemberton I'm a doctor a
journalist and editor a spectator health
in recent years more and more the
government has looked to industry and
big business to help it deliver on
public health initiatives a key aspect
to this is it is in the interests of
business to diversify and innovate and
through this they will develop healthier
better products but can we really trust
businesses to innovate do they have a
duty to the public good or just to their
shareholders I want to explore where the
responsibilities lie for improving
people's health is it with the
government is it with individuals or is
it with industry to start off with I'm
going to speak to dr. Sarah Jarosz she's
an NHS GP and she's also on the medical
board for the charity drinks aware which
promotes sensible drinking Sarah one of
the policies that medicine has adopted
in recent years is that of harm
reduction can you explain what actually
means the trouble is in an ideal world
we'd love it if everybody had the
healthiest the balanced diets with seven
portions of vegetable and fruit exercise
for half an hour five days a week was
not remotely overweight had never
touched a cigarette in their lives and
drank two glasses of wine a week it
doesn't happen and it's not going to
happen so unfortunately what we see is
if we go around banging on about how
this is the only way to live healthily
then people just say well I can't do
that so much well not bother effectively
I think a much more realistic way of
doing it is saying let's look at how we
can help you to make small changes and
the classic example was the guidance
which came out from nice on smoking
where they were talking not about
smoking cessation and about saying right
there is only one way to go we need to
think as an alternative about reducing
tobacco related home so what we're
talking to people about now is
alternatives there's a lot of
controversy about vaping and I don't
think there's any doubt that we don't
have enough proof
if it's ever going to be there to say it
is completely safe but what we do know
is that it's considerably less harmful
than smoking so therefore we've moved
from saying we're not going to recommend
it because we don't know if it's
completely safe to saying actually we
may not know it's completely safe but we
do know that you can considerably reduce
harm by switching from normal cigarettes
to vaping or by using nicotine
replacement therapy long-term rather
than just using it for the short term
while you're trying to get off
cigarettes as a strategy how successful
has harm reduction beam if you look at
countries like safe Finland where they
had a huge national push towards
reducing their incredibly high rate of
heart attack and stroke they managed to
cut the rate of heart attack and stroke
in finland by two-thirds over the course
of not more than a decade so seventy
percent of strokes and heart attacks
gone almost overnight why because the
government said you need to do this you
need to make dramatic changes you need
to jump and the population said how high
to work then do you think business or
industry should be involved in public
health initiatives I think industry has
an enormously important part to play in
public health initiatives and the food
industry is an absolutely classic
example of that in the last ten years
the amount of salt in tomato ketchup in
the UK like the amount of salt in
cornflakes a few years earlier has gone
down considerably but that's because
every company has worked together
they've worked with public health and
they've done it very very gradually so
that the population hasn't noticed it
happening and we're now not used to it
you've been involved in drinker where
it's funded by the drinks industry so
why should we believe what it tells us
well from my perspective I worked with
it for a very long time I am aware that
in some other countries there has been
controversy about how closely their
countries drink aware has worked with
their government but they are completely
independent of ours all I can say to you
is as a member of the medical advisory
panel I have never been told what to do
I've never been told to change anything
that I do
and anything that we take to them they
take seriously to what extent do you
think that the individual should take
responsibility for their health versus
government or industry so yes people do
need to take responsibility but
unfortunately these are addictions and
in the NHS we do not nor should we
discriminate against people on the basis
of their life choices or whether their
illnesses are caused by their life
choices or by simple peddler Sarah seems
really positive about the role that
industry has had in harm reduction she
still sees though the main thrust of
initiatives coming from government loan
I want to know what the libertarian
perspective or Sam Bowman is executive
director of the adam smith institute i
think tank that champions individual
choice I'm wary of placing the
responsibility holy in industry because
some people would argue they often part
of the problem to what extent do you
think they can also be part of the
solution I think we shouldn't be
expecting the industry to do this kind
of out of the goodness of their own
hearts really for them it's about profit
and that's actually a good thing there's
been a big big shift among smokers and
among drinkers in the last couple of
years in part we have to say thanks to
the government's very very sort of stern
anti-drinking anti-smoking campaigns a
big shift towards the idea of harm
reduction and towards the idea that
these things have costs and benefits now
as a liberal I think that we should let
people decide whether the benefits
outweigh the costs to them but if there
is a demand for products that are lower
costs but still pretty high benefits
things like e-cigarettes or things like
synthetic alcohol and the industry could
wants to satisfy that demand there's an
incentive for them to provide better
products and to provide safer products
now what we're talking about today is
products that are superior in safety
terms so if you are a bit if you're a
business you can offer for example an
e-cigarette or some other kind of
reduced risk tobacco product that's
almost as good as a cigarette but
significantly safer then you will we
assume attract more smokers who care
about their health I think what we
should trust is in competition and in
the kind of legal mechanisms that we
have to punish firms that are dishonest
and so it's that kind of mechanism of
competition that I generally think
maintain standard
isn't the easiest answer for government
to simply ban things that are
detrimental to people's health certainly
government has a role in educating
people if that education isn't taking
place kind of privately I think perhaps
we go too far in the direction of trying
to scare people off and trying to sort
of our only metric is reducing the
number of smokers or reducing the number
of drinkers what I would like to see is
metrics that look at the benefits and
the costs people and check that people
know about the costs that they're
incurring on to themselves that's the
role for government really because when
it comes to adults we generally in a
liberal society think that nobody except
the individual themselves is equipped to
know whether the costs outweigh the
benefits what are your thoughts on
synthetic alcohol I mean that's that's
like a perfect example of innovation
that has come up against government
legislation isn't it yeah I mean
synthetic alcohol is a really
interesting example it reputedly does
the same thing to your brain that
alcohol does but doesn't do the same
thing to your liver to the rest of your
internal organs that alcohol does so it
causes much less long-term damage I
think that this should go through very
very rigorous checks to make sure that
these claims are actually true that's
not what the government is doing the
government is really just treating this
like it's you know poison and and not
giving it any kind of route through
testing through a kind of an approvals
process where all we need to do is find
out what it does and then inform
consumers about what it does so that
they can make a choice for themselves
that's what I think the real key for
government is now is to create a
regulatory pathway it's from the point
of developing a drug like this to
testing it and to marketing it to
consumers that doesn't exist at the
moment finally I'm gonna speak to Chris
Snowden head of lifestyle economics at
the Institute of Economic Affairs I want
to know whether it is actually good
business for companies to innovate and
produce products that actually reduce
heart
should industry take a lead in
addressing public health concerns rather
than just waiting to be asked I think
when it comes to innovation in hazardous
product categories it's bound to be
industry who lived way the government is
unlikely to come up with any novel
innovations itself the businesses have
got huge incentives as a serious demand
for low sugar drinks smoking to be made
less hazardous for drinking to be made
safer so I think the basic laws of
supply and demand mean that businesses
will respond and it really the only
people who can respond is it actually
good business for companies to produce
products things like say electric cars
low-alcohol beer low-fat foods yeah
there's a huge amount of money up for
grabs for any company that can come up
with something that reduces the
negatives from a product reduces the
risks reduces the cost whatever it may
be you know it's a basic cost benefit
analysis if you can reduce those costs
in terms of health risks and the kind of
examples you're giving there you got a
massive competitive advantage and
everybody else on stuff to follow you
what about harm reduction sure door or
can industry be part of the solution do
you think well there's various types of
tobacco harm reduction and if you look
at the most obvious and oldest one its
nicotine patches and nicotine gum again
they came from business from the
pharmaceutical industry more recently
you've had swedish snus its back up
right of course e cigarettes and other
products along the way such as he'd not
burn so these have all come from
business primarily and I think it's only
natural that that it should do I think
obviously they have to have a part to
play I think they've got a very major
part to play because they're the ones
who have the know-how have the money and
have the incentives to do it did anyone
trust industry to be unbiased in the
research that they conduct well I don't
see why the taxpayer should have to be
paying for businesses to do research it
seems to me that there are indie should
be something that comes out of their own
budget and I don't think it's a really a
question of trust I think it should just
go through the peer-reviewed journals be
put up in front of the side scientific
Academy as you would any other and you
have a forum researched Russian really
be a part of
[Music]
for my conversations it seems the
industry does have a critical role in
harm reduction and public health
initiatives the biggest innovations in
public health from e-cigarettes to
electric cars have come from industry
not government it's clear though that
these are only part of the solution
there has to be government frameworks in
place to enable innovation and also the
individual has to take ultimate
responsibility for harm reduction
[Music]